welcome ladies and gentlemen we're going
to begin in just a few minutes my name
is Dan SD I'm a professor in the yale
law school and the Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies and
it's my great privilege to welcome you
all here today to the Yale conference of
Governors on climate change for those
who have not been part of the program
over the last day and a half let me just
share with you a little bit about what
we've been up to we are waiting by the
way for our guests of honor to arrive
and as soon as they do we will proceed
with our program first we have begun to
focus on the critical issue of climate
change as a challenge for our country
and frankly for the world beyond we have
with us several governor's
representatives of a dozen more states
and a number of foreign countries as we
think through what it's going to take to
move our country towards a successful
strategy of reducing greenhouse gases
and frankly beyond that and beyond the
domestic politics of that challenge what
it takes to bring the world together in
a unified effort to address this very
significant policy issue we have spent
the last day in a bit talking about
climate change and celebrating in
particular state level leadership on
this issue and I can't help as a
professor but offer a little bit of a
lesson on federalism one of the great
strengths of our country is that we have
multiple layers of government sometimes
it can be a burden complicates the
division of responsibilities it's
sometimes leads to overlaps and
sometimes to gaps but in the case that
we face with climate change I think we
can be grateful that state level
leadership has provided a safety net
beneath which we have protected
ourselves against policy failure in
Washington and we honor today not just
the current leadership of a number of
states 18 of whom had signed a
declaration that we will present in a
few minutes but we honor as well the
effort begun a hundred years ago by
President Teddy Roosevelt to engage the
state
in a partnership with the federal
government and his effort in the spring
of nineteen oh eight was to take on the
critical environmental issue of that era
the need to protect our nation's natural
resources to conserve our land and to
ensure that the great natural treasures
of the United States were preserved for
generations to come and President
Roosevelt's efforts not only produced a
National Forest Service a national park
system but an enormous number of other
initiatives that have continued to serve
as well to this day not all federal
initiatives many of them state efforts
so we honor today Teddy Roosevelt's
tradition and that commitment to action
that he was so famous for we also want
to focus today on the critical issue of
our era climate change the build-up of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere that
threatens not only global warming rising
sea levels changed rainfall patterns
more intense wind storms and a host of
other potential risks and threats and we
do want to honor the states that have
done so much to take leadership we will
hear from Governor rel in a few minutes
about the Connecticut perspective on
this a second major goal of our
conference over the last day and a half
has been to begin some difficult
conversations but essential
conversations about how we unify state
and federal efforts how we ensure that
the federal government learns from the
state experiences in addressing this
problem and we build on the base that
the states have already established we
have been talking about the best
practices the models that have been
developed in a number of states and
thinking about what hasn't worked as
well as what has so that we can move
forward more quickly as a nation and of
course we want to build on that state
experience not only to know what's
environmentally effective but also
what's efficient and cost-effective so
we are very pleased we've had that
conversation and you see it on the stage
a number of the state officials who've
been leading the charge in their own
regions of the country a third goal of
and really a critical one is to honor
Yale's environmental tradition in that
effort a hundred years ago the President
Roosevelt led he had at his side a Yale
man Gifford Pinchot who was President
Roosevelt's top advisor on issues
related to environment and what they
thought of at the time as land
conservation Gifford Pinchot played a
number of roles not only as a critical
advisor to Roosevelt and a friend of the
presidents and a confidante and someone
who bounced ideas back and forth with
the president to develop them but
Gifford Pinchot also was the first head
of the National Forest Service and
played an absolutely critical role in
laying a foundation for the Yale School
of Forestry and environmental studies
that is today a leading example of an
academic commitment to environmental
protection broadly and a continuing
commitment to forests as well and for
those who didn't see it yesterday the
spirit of commitment of the students in
the School of Forestry and environmental
studies was on beautiful display those
of you who know the school know that
above the front door of sage hall is a
statue called sage boy and sage boy gets
decorated in ways that reflect the
season and on Valentine's Day he may
have a pink outfit on st. Patrick's Day
green yesterday he was wrapped with a VW
Bug and a series of comments on the
challenge of stepping up to greenhouse
gas emissions reduction that we face as
a society so let me honor the spirit of
our students of the school of Forestry
and environmental studies and so many
others who are part of that tribute
I wanted to say that before President
Levin arrived because it took the
university authorities most of the
morning to bring down the car that was
perched precariously above the door of
the school and which the public health
authorities declared to be a nuisance
preventing anyone from going in or out
so that was of course a bit of a
challenge as well let me say one other
thing and that is it is a great honor to
be part of a yale community that has
stepped up to the climate change issue
not just in a theoretical manner but in
a practical and real way on this campus
and president levin who some of you know
is a hard-nosed economist has really led
the charge he's become a national leader
on climate change he's spoken out
forcefully and thoughtfully about not
all the importance of taking on this
issue but the fact that it can be done
in a way that's economically sensible
and need not be damaging to our economy
so I think it is a great privilege to be
part of a university that has led by
someone who is taking a strong stand and
become a real leader across our society
in fact yale university has over the
last couple of years reduced its
greenhouse gas emissions by seventeen
percent and that's not bad for one
little university
and some of you will know that is
starting to be a real debate about how
our country is going to go forward are
we going to use a cap-and-trade
allowance system should we move to
carbon charges do we need some structure
of old style command and control
mandates perhaps to ensure that we step
up to the issue of how to green our
buildings ensure that they're efficient
and reduce greenhouse gas emissions in
the housing and residential sector where
so much of our missions take place well
I think one of the things that
universities have long done and I'm
pleased to say Yale is continuing to do
it is to think not only about the
policies that will be necessary to make
that happen across the country not only
to design incentive structures and to
build a base that the rest of the world
can look at and understand as a
theoretical foundation for this kind of
policy intervention but we've also tried
to live it ourselves and we have changed
in a number of ways how we do business
what we do and it puts some real
investments into what we are living in
our own lives so we have a bio diesel
bus bringing our distinguished visitors
from the president's house and we have
done so many other things to help reduce
those missions and we have a commitment
to continue to do so and to demonstrate
not only the possibilities but that
there is a cost-effective way of going
forward without any further ado I'm
going to step back and let our
distinguished guests enter and thank you
all again for being with us
we are very pleased not only to have
leadership in the University in the form
of President 11 but leadership in the
state of the Connecticut in the form of
Governor Jodi Rell and it is with great
flavors I introduced her to speak
thank you very much Dan I appreciate
that introduction I have to tell all of
you the closest I'm ever going to get to
a Yale graduation was just now and that
that was wonderful thank you president
11 of course burren for the initiative
today and i have to tell you Yale has
just absolutely been wonderful in
organizing and of course in hosting this
historic summit your efforts are
appreciated by all and especially all of
us who are sitting up here when you turn
the air conditioner on in just a little
while I know its climate change we're
not talking about air conditioning today
but in keeping with leadership shown by
Yale on issue of climate change under
your stewardship Yale committed to the
goal of reducing greenhouse gas
emissions you also had the foresight to
engage students in this important effort
in fact because of Yale's comprehensive
approach you received the climate change
leadership award last year from
Connecticut Governor steering committee
on climate change ladies and gentlemen
that is a well-deserved honor
congratulations
so thank you president Lebanon for all
that you and Yale are doing for for
being such gracious host today and of
course I'd like to extend a warm welcome
to all of you as well it's wonderful to
have so many governors here today the
Canadian premiers and so many other top
leaders from states and nations many
distinguished guests are here as well
now I have to make a pitch or it
wouldn't be normal but I want you to
enjoy Connecticut while you're here I
ordered the weather specifically for
governor Sebelius from Kansas that it
snowed there last weekend don't tell her
it snowed here recently as well I want
you to also get a good taste of the
Nutmeg hospitality and I hope that you
will all return when your schedules are
not quite as condensed and compressed as
they are now filing I want to thank the
foundation partners who worked so
closely with Yale to transform what was
originally just a vision into today's
reality you have been wonderful and a
special thank you too Stuart Hudson of
the Tremaine foundation Stuart where are
you stand up
I have to tell you that Stewart played a
critical role in supporting this summit
as well as Connecticut's overall efforts
to address climate change so today we're
really here to commemorate a true
milestone in in our nation's efforts to
preserve natural resources and of course
that milestone is the fact that of
course we had a presidental hundred
years ago who said you know what we're
going to set a new course and our hope
today is that we will continue to set a
new course have a courageous new
approach to environmental challenges to
the environmental challenges of our own
era the milestone that we celebrate
today of course is the historic meeting
at the White House 100 years ago this
may in 1908 President Theodore Roosevelt
convened the conference of Governors
just as a side note I want to share with
you that my fellow governors and I were
in Washington in February and we
actually stood on the White House and
had a picture taken of all of the
governor's today just to show what we
looked like a hundred years later to all
of you that wonder there were no women
of course in that picture a hundred
years ago the men all had bushy bushy
sideburns and big mustaches and I think
Kathleen Sebelius and I stood out pretty
well on that day and it was nice to see
the change and the color in that
photograph as well but joining President
Theodore Roosevelt that day and had his
side was Gifford Pinchot founder of Yale
School of Forestry who later went on to
serve as the first chief of the u.s.
Forest Service at that conference a
partnership was born between the states
and the federal government that
partnership grew into the modern
conservation movement it also planted
the seed for the remarkable system that
we know is the national parks and
forests by working together President
Roosevelt and governors of that era
successfully met the challenges they
faced they found a way to preserve the
matchless natural resources
and to continue the economic growth and
prosperity that our nation needed this
is the legacy that we have been given
this is our challenge we haven't
inherited it and we will do well with it
today we're here is a new generation
joining us or President Roosevelt's
great-grandson Theodore Roosevelt the
fourth Ted please stand
and we have gifford pinchot grandson
gifford pinchot the third gift please
stand
just as those great conservationists
before us we must reach out across
geographic and political divides across
state boundaries and provincial lines
and yes across party lines as well we
seek partnerships with the federal
government we want their help in helping
us to predict the protect the fragile
planet we call home and build
sustainable in a prosperous 21st century
economy for all of our citizens over the
past few years all governors and
premieres states and provinces have
represented that are represented in this
room along with many colleagues have
taken issue taken action on the issues
of climate change it's been hard and
it's been a lot of work but all of us in
our own states and through the regional
alliances have formed things like the
Regional Greenhouse Gas Initiative here
in the Northeast with counterparts that
are in the Western heaven established
the western climate initiative and the
Midwest greenhouse gas Accord the spirit
of cooperation of almost 40 states as
well as several Canadian provinces and
mexican states to form the climate
registry an organization that supports
both voluntary and mandatory efforts to
report greenhouse gas emissions during
this time we have come to realize that
we must take steps to lower carbon
emissions and like investments in energy
and fishin sea and shift to clean
renewable energy not just to save this
planet but also to set the foundation
for a new economy this will be a new
economy that embraces innovation and new
technologies and it grows on the
existing green collar jobs and allows us
to reduce dependence on foreign oil here
in Connecticut we have companies at the
forefront of these new technologies
companies like United Technologies in
general electric and we have training
programs and some that we've just
enhanced even more this year to help
prepare our students for what we call
the green collar jobs of today and to
in Connecticut were determined more to
do more than just to sit around and
acknowledge what is ahead we are
actually embracing these opportunities
and this challenge that it opens for all
of us for new opportunities you know
Teddy Roosevelt once said believe you
can and you're halfway there I believe
we can and I know you do too that is our
focus and that's what we're going to do
and talk about today in our energies and
our challenges I just want to share one
thing with you it is the one thing
project that I started last year last
summer here in Connecticut I asked
people across the state to do one thing
one thing every day to help save energy
now I started out doing this kind of in
a funny way because I heard from someone
that if you unplug your cell phone or
your blackberry unplug it from the wall
and from the phone and you save energy
well I tried it out on the first morning
I was into this campaign and it was my
husband's phone figured he wouldn't miss
it and I unplugged it of course I moved
the phone but it was the one thing that
caught my attention and what we started
really has started across the state in
fact it truly has caught on think about
this there are three and a half million
people in the state of Connecticut if
each of us did one thing every single
day think how many one things that
really could be that's a potential for
three and a half million one things
every day and if we each did one thing
every day for a year it's more than two
billion one things now if you're like me
you probably hear your parents head
voices in the back of your head
somewhere as you're walking out of a
room I grew up in Virginia my father
used to say I'm not supporting vep go
turn the lights off now it's whatever
Electric Company is helping you but it's
one thing that each of us can do every
day
one thing turned the lights off unplug
the cell phone turn off the appliance
that you're not using whatever it
happens to be the reason I bring this up
to you today is because it's a positive
thing and that's what we need to focus
on how we can be positive while we're
teaching people how we're going to save
our planet so enjoy this conference
you've got a lot of great speakers and I
look forward to talking with you later
thanks everyone
so Thank You governor rel the next part
of our program is the signing of the
governor's declaration on climate change
being released here at Yale in new haven
connecticut today committing 18 states
representing more than half the US
population more than half of the u.s.
emissions to climate change action
this promises a real step forward a
serious step forward a step forward in
terms of reducing emissions not in
theory but in practice on the ground
with real results and if the state's
committing to action today were
countries they would be equivalent in
their emissions to Britain France
Germany and Italy so this is a
substantial commitment from very
substantial part of the US economy the
governor's were signing up today
represent Republicans as well as
Democrats they're from the south as well
as the north from the east and from the
west and from the great heartland in the
middle so I think it represents more
than just a commitment to action it
represents commitment to a new way
forward on climate change as governor
rel has said it represents bringing us
together recognizing this is an issue
without partisan divide it's an issue
that will take every one of us doing our
part the declaration has three critical
points it commits the governor's to
working to ensure a workable
federal-state partnership recognizing
the need for federal mandatory
regulation and state level
implementation it urges building on
state experience and of course we do
have states that have led the charge and
if we're going to have an effective
program and an efficient one that is
cost-effective as well we have to build
on that state experience and it talks
importantly about getting the incentives
right recognizing that the key to policy
is engaging every industry in the
country and all of us as individuals in
guiding the country forward in a way
that makes real emissions reductions so
if I could invite governor rel to add
her signature that would be a great
pleasure right here in front
one after another
yep
a governor corzine could I invite you to
sign and briefly address the audience
thank you Dan and it is a great honor to
be with all of you today I bring
greetings from the Princeton Tigers to
all of you let me let me say that I
think you were seeing a historic
statement that with your Republican or a
Democrat whether you're from the north
of south they used to the West that
there is a challenge for all of us in
our common humanity to push back against
the threat of climate change we are
making a statement that together our
citizens believe that we should move
forward in a strong and certain way in
partnership our states federal
government and ultimately with the globe
at large and I am very very pleased that
New Jersey is a signer of this and we
will work to make it at reality in the
future thank
Thank You Governor Corzine governor
Sebelius
well I bring you greetings from the
heartland and the championship Kansas
Jayhawks say hello
I also want to thank of Anna rel and
Yale for this wonderful opportunity to
bring governor's together in person and
many of us are here in spirit to join in
this incredibly important initiative a
hundred years ago governors came
together as governor l reminded us with
then President Theodore Roosevelt to
start the great conservation movement
the steps we're taking today as
governors joining together to declare
our interest in taking seriously the
threat of greenhouse gas emissions and
taking steps toward America being a
leader in this process once again are
equally important for the next hundred
years so I appreciate the opportunity to
be a signature from the heartland and
feel this is a critical step forward
thank
Thank You governor Sebelius I also want
to acknowledge a number of leaders
who've joined us on the podium from
Canada from Mexico the Deputy Prime
Minister and Environment Minister of the
Czech Republic this is again not just a
u.s. challenge but one that will require
all of us to pull together from across
the globe thank you for your presence
so I'd like to invite our governor's to
come forward for a picture with
President Levin
so I'd like to invite all of the podium
forward all the present for the picture
of us all together
thank you
all right thank you all very much
governor schwarzenegger will now sign
the petition
phase two of our program members of the
Yale community and distinguished guests
as a resident of Connecticut I want to
thank you governor rel for all that
you're doing to develop strategies to
address the problem of climate change
you led Connecticut to participate in
the Regional Greenhouse Gas Initiative
the first in the nation cap-and-trade
program to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions you're spearheading a climate
registry where states can manage a
common greenhouse gas emissions
reporting system and you will be
implementing green building requirements
next year for new public and private
construction of buildings that cost more
than 5 million dollars and this is only
the beginning of your initiatives as a
citizen of the United States I am proud
of the efforts of Governors Corzine
sibelius and Schwarzenegger and I'm
grateful for the efforts of the
commissioners and the other officials of
the states represented here who have
already signed on to today's declaration
the leaders from Canada India the Czech
Republic and Mexico who are here today
reinforced by their presence the
absolute necessity of global partnership
to save the planet no nation acting
alone can stop global warming as
president of Yale University i want to
say what a proud day this is for our
university to host this conference and
to witness this declaration that calls
for federal-state partnership on the
issue of climate policy you know you've
heard those who were here this morning
about Yale's leadership and the
environmental movement for over a
century professor SD who has convened
this conference was the chief negotiator
for the 1992 framework and Keith us
negotiator for the 1992 framework
convention on climate change and the
Dean of Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies Gus Speth which
joins us on stage was a founder of two
of the most important environmental
organizations in the
States the natural resources defense
council and the world resources
institute it's not only the faculty at
Yale who are offering environmental
leadership students from our school of
Forestry and environmental studies are
preparing themselves for careers of
stewards of our environment but even
this is not enough our university is an
institution that is leading by example
by our commitment to reducing greenhouse
gas emissions to ten percent below 1990
levels by 2020 a forty three percent
reduction from our 2005 level our
sustainability program at Yale begins
with educating the next generation of
leaders our students to live in better
harmony with the planet than prior
generations our aspiration is to promote
growing prosperity that is sustainable
in the sense that future generations
will have no less opportunity to enjoy
the fruits of the environment or the
fruits of their own potential than we
ourselves have enjoyed I'm pleased to
report that we've made real progress in
our first two years we have reduced our
greenhouse gas emissions already by
seventeen percent from our 2005 levels
and we've added we have underway
additional projects that will cut
another seventeen percent in three years
at this rate we will reach our goal well
in advance of the deadline that we set
for ourselves and we're demonstrating
that the reduction of our carbon
footprint is not only feasible but
affordable we estimate that we can
achieve our targeted reductions at a
cost of less than one percent of our
operating expenses perhaps no more than
one half of one percent and who among us
would not be willing to pay a tax of one
half of one percent to save the planet
Yale has made an institutional effort to
signal the dangers of global warming and
to take action to prevent it we hope
that institutions can make a difference
but we all know that it is ultimately
individuals who make the biggest
difference
leaders who awaken and inspire us all we
are fortunate today to have two such
inspirational leaders to address us so
let me proceed to introduce the first of
these my distinguished friend and
colleague Rajendra Pachauri
mr. Pachauri is one of the world's
leading environmentalists he has spent
his life helping to save our planet he's
chairman of the Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change an international
organization that seeks to combat global
warming in 2019 in 2007 the IPCC
presented the most convincing scientific
evidence to date of the direct
relationship between global warming and
human activity the panel's assessment of
the human contribution to global warming
has been accepted and endorsed by
governments and scientific bodies of
more than 150 nations as a result of mr.
Patrese leadership the IPCC was a
co-recipient of the 2007 Nobel Peace
Prize a major recognition that the peace
and prosperity of the world depends upon
protecting the planet
since its formation the IPCC has been a
leading voice promoting awareness of the
impact of climate change mr. Pachauri
authored the second IPCC report in 1995
which laid much of the foundation of the
Kyoto agreement in 1997 we all hope that
the fourth report released last year
will play a similar role as the
foundation for a successor agreement in
Copenhagen in 2009 Yale prides itself on
being a global university we're reaching
out to all parts of the world to
disseminate information to educate our
students and the students from other of
other countries to carry out research
that will advance our understanding of
the human and natural world increasingly
we understand that being part of a
global university means caring for the
globe itself and that we must educate
the next generation of leaders to do the
same mr. Pachauri is helping us do that
by the example he sets in his own
organization and by the wise counsel and
instruction he has and will continue to
offer on this campus in partnership with
Dean Gus Speth he's been instrumental in
creating Yale's strong connection to his
home institution the energy and
resources institute where he serves as
director general the collaboration has
been a cornerstone of eels presence in
india and it emphasizes the teaching
training and research in areas of energy
climate change and carbon sequestration
Environmental Law and Policy joint
forests and watershed management and
industrial ecology he has been a
frequent guest on our campus and he's
and we're so pleased that he'll be back
again in the fall once again to teach
our students please join me in welcoming
Rajendra Pachauri
president 11 honorable governor's my
good friends Dean gospel and professor
dynasty I feel very humble here with
leaders who have achieved so much and
all I've done is basically to have been
responsible for the production of the
fourth assessment report of the IPCC and
to have in my own humble way spread the
message in different parts of the world
but I salute president 11 for the
initiative that he's taken in making
Yale a leader in actually doing what
really the whole world should be doing
and I have to I certainly owe a debt of
gratitude to Governor Schwarzenegger and
governor el because they have done
things that have certainly made my life
much easier in the sense that whenever I
go I'm asked by the media what I think
about the actions of the United States
administration and as a stateless person
and the reason why I'm a stateless
person is because I traveled so much
from one state to the other and barely
spent any time there I am always able to
provide comfort by saying look at
California look at Connecticut look at
some of the states in the US and don't
worry about what the administration says
that certainly seems my skin because
otherwise I'd have to say something
critical about the administration and
get into trouble for doing that well let
me start by saying that climate change
by itself is part of a much larger
problem the problem essentially is that
in our drive towards industrialization
and being able to provide more and more
goods and services to human society
we have actually pursued a path of
development which is unsustainable its
unsustainable because we have been
consuming natural resources and I've
been deriving the services of the
ecosystems and natural resources in a
manner that clearly has not been able to
replenish what we have consumed and in
the case of climate change we know that
industrialization has brought with it
excessive consumption of fossil fuels
excuse me hand and the production of
several other greenhouse gases which
have taken us to a level where climate
change is not merely scientific theory
it's something which we can observe love
the observations are so strong that it
would be really someone totally naive or
unable to see things around him to say
that climate change is merely a myth if
we look at the observations before us
and we have brought this out clearly in
the fourth assessment report of the IPCC
the average increase in temperature
during the 20th century has been zero
point 74 degrees Celsius this
incidentally is much higher than what we
had estimated earlier in the third
assessment report we're iced mate was
0.6 degree Celsius sea level rise during
the century roads on an average 17
centimeters and if you look at the
warmest years in history if we classify
12 of the warmest years since
instrumental records have been
maintained across the globe 11 of the 12
warmest have occurred in the last 12
years
so it would be fair to conclude that the
rate of warming is on an increase but
climate change is not something that's a
simple straight linear relationship it's
something that's accompanied by a large
number of other changes which
essentially include changes in
precipitation levels in general at the
upper latitudes precipitation has been
increasing in fact I remember for years
ago there was a major conference in
Moscow called the world climate change
conference where President Putin spoke
and opened the conference and he read
out a text which was quite uninspiring
and everybody thought Russia is not
going to ratify the Kyoto Protocol then
closed off fer then he was the head of
UNEP at that point of time the then
executive secretary of the UN Framework
Convention and I spoke in succession and
I talked about the impacts of climate
change on the developing countries and
then President Putin did this and he
wanted to speak again this time he spoke
without any notes and he says everybody
tells me that climate change is good for
Russia because we won't have to spend so
much on fur coats and that several areas
will open up and we up agriculture will
prosper he said but I have to worry
about floods I have to worry about
droughts and I certainly have to worry
about all of these happenings in the
rest of the world and I felt his body
language conveyed the fact that Russia
would ratify the Kyoto Protocol the
reason why I'm mentioning this is
because with this increase in
precipitation those and I've discussed
this with people from Siberia those in
Siberia who feel that happy days are
ahead
would be disillusioned because there
would be so much more snowfall that in
effect life would become much more
difficult so climate change is not
something that's a smooth linear
increase in temperatures it involves as
we know now much different precipitation
patterns certainly many more extreme
precipitation events that means in short
periods of time you will get large
quantities of rainfall as has been
happening in several parts of the globe
much more floods much more droughts and
more severe floods and most severe
droughts they would be there for a major
change in the availability of water in
different parts of the world coming as I
do from the Indian subcontinent we know
that the glaciers are melting at such a
rapid rate that the flow in our river
systems at least in the northern part of
the subcontinent will be severely
affected and this we have estimated in
the IPCC will influence the lives of 500
million people in South Asia and 250
million people in China so we have some
serious problems that are part of this
process of human-induced climate change
there are also impacts on agriculture
and the net effect of climate change on
agriculture would be one that would
essentially lead to a decline in yields
and productivity and I don't have to
remind you about the seriousness of this
problem because you know what's
happening around the world today food
prices have gone up demand is increasing
supply has not kept pace and therefore
as a result in some of the poorest
countries in the world you have
demonstrations you have riots and people
who are going hungry this I'm afraid is
going to increase in the future and
there's no part of the globe that can
remain immune to the danger that's
inherent in these problems and these
situations so the impacts of climate
change overall are going to become
much more severe including the impacts
on human health now some of these will
occur because there would be much
greater vector-borne disease in
different parts of the world because
these vectors are going to be able to
survive in the revised climatic
conditions that we are going to deal
with but there would also be more floods
more droughts and certainly more heat
waves I don't have to remind you about
what happened in 2003 in France where
and other parts of Europe where 30,000
people lost their lives as a result and
this incidentally in the developing
countries is of any normal occurrence
but you don't normally read about it
simply because it doesn't hit the
headlines so help and mortality and
morbidity would be much more of a
problem in the future our projections
indicate that by the end of the 21st
century average temperature increase at
the lower end of the scenarios that we
have assessed would be 1.8 degrees
Celsius and at the upper end we have a
best estimate of four degrees Celsius
now even the lower end is something that
clearly the human race cannot accept
because combined with the 0.74 degree
increase that took place in the 20th
century this would represent a total
increase since industrialization began
of over 2.5 degrees Celsius what would
happen at this range of 2.5 degrees
Celsius well agriculture we know now we
have enough evidence will be severely
effective there are there is a danger of
several species being endangered and
perhaps being driven to extinction the
IPCC has assessed a large number of
species and we find that twenty to
thirty percent of these species are a
danger of extinction at temperatures
above 1.5 to 2.5 degrees Celsius another
important issue that we need to be
concerned about
is the possibility of abrupt and
reversible changes I have already
mentioned the danger to species but
another particularly dangerous and
severe consequence that we might see is
going to result from the possible
collapse of the ice sheet in Greenland
and West Antarctica now these are large
bodies of ice that are sitting on land
and therefore if they were to collapse
the extent of increase in sea level
could be several meters and that clearly
means that we as a species would have
succeeded in changing the geography of
this planet and it certainly would put
at risk several hundreds of millions of
people in the small island states in
countries like Bangladesh even parts of
North America which are low-lying they
would clearly be affected as a result of
the kind of sea level rise that would
occur now one important part of the
framework convention on climate change
is the central objective of preventing
dangerous anthropogenic or human
interference with the climate system the
big question is what represents
dangerous and we the IPCC have been
asked that question frequently but
unfortunately the answer to that has to
be based on value judgments science can
only assist in arriving at this
conclusion and science can tell you that
at certain temperature levels with
certain levels of temperate climate
change we are likely to get a whole
range of consequences in terms of
impacts of climate change but then it's
for the negotiate it is for the
policymakers to decide what they should
term as dangerous and here may I say
that the definition of what is dangerous
depends on whose perspective you're
reflecting if you talk to the president
of the Maldives as indeed I have done
he'll tell you that that danger point
was exceeded several years ago in 1997
the IPCC had a meeting in the Maldive
islands
and the president of Maldives president
Gayoom stood before us and he says
ladies and gentlemen the place where
you're holding this meeting 10 years ago
was under a foot and a half of water
because you don't have to wait for these
small island states and low-lying areas
to be inundated by the sea the danger is
present the moment you find sea level
has reached a certain magnitude any
storm surge any cyclone any such event
will produce a devastating effect in
particular the mega Delta's across the
world are very vulnerable and this
includes cities like Shanghai kolkata in
dhaka i was in china last week and i
spoke at the bois forum and when I told
the Chinese that Shanghai is in danger
they certainly felt a bit uncomfortable
because this is the shining example of
modern China and if that's endangered
and there's something for them to worry
about now I really don't want to go into
this story of creating a scare but I do
want to emphasize that science tells us
very clearly now that with the changes
that are taking place there is clearly
the threat to peace and stability and I
suppose the Norwegian Nobel Committee
realized that when they awarded last
year's nobel peace prize to the IDCC and
Mr Al Gore we know however that in the
event of these changes we will have to
adapt to climate change because there's
a certain inertia in the system by which
even if we were to stabilize the
concentration of these greenhouse gases
in the atmosphere at today's level
climate change will continue for several
decades so some countries and some
regions have no choice but to urgently
implement adaptation measures and I
think the global community has to help
these societies simply because they are
the most underprivileged and the poorest
regions of the world but that will
in itself not be enough we really need
to mitigate the emissions of greenhouse
gases because unless we do that the
impacts will become so severe that it
will exceed the capacity of human human
society to be able to adapt to the kinds
of changes that we are going to see as
it happens the good news is that
mitigation is not an expensive
proposition as indeed we have seen in
the case of the states that are
represented by the governor's over here
we in the IPCC have assessed several
scenarios for stabilization and one of
them just to mention some details would
essentially stabilize temperature
increase at two to two point four
degrees Celsius what would this imply
well firstly that all we have is a short
window of seven years emissions globally
will have to peak by 2015 and then
decline thereafter so that gives us a
very short period of time that's why
it's so critical that in 2009 we had a
firm and forward-looking agreement that
helps to bring down the emissions of
greenhouse gases as required and if
people tell you that the cost of
mitigation is going to be very high then
I think they need to be disputed because
if you look at the cost of mitigation
and the scenario that i just mentioned
to you in 20-30 the total cost to the
global economy will be less than three
percent of the gdp certainly not a high
price to pay for avoiding all the
dangerous impacts and damage that might
take place in the future and what's more
important is that these mitigation
measures carry with them a whole range
of so-called co-benefits energy security
lower levels of air pollution better
health benefits in some areas rural jobs
being created all of this once you add
it together might actually give you
negative costs that means society may
actually benefit by taking these
measures so the myth that there would be
a loss of jobs
and economic output needs to be exploded
and indeed our numbers clearly explored
that may I now end by putting before you
a few thoughts which I think are
critical from the point of view of the
u.s. we need leadership the US has been
a leader in several areas where
Democratic initiatives are involved but
today may I say very candidly it bothers
me that the prestige that the u.s. had
acquired through all these years of
practice of democracy and concern for
the rest of the world is being severely
questioned and is certainly not at the
level where it was it's a good thing as
I mentioned at the outset that we have
governor's we have state leadership
that's really showing us the way but
there is a need for the country as a
whole to move forward in this respect
may I say that even companies that have
the wisdom to see that the world is
going to move towards a low-carbon
future and are therefore investing in
technologies that are low in carbon
intensity are going to be winners those
who lag behind will certainly be losers
and this argument also applies to
countries those countries which are
prepared to take the leadership and
therefore all the businesses in industry
located in those countries will turn out
to be winners and those who are left
behind will obviously lose prestige
global influence and perhaps even market
opportunities in the world of the future
now we are told that technology is going
to provide the answers yes undoubtedly
but technology can only follow what
policies require and in order to bring
about technological change and the
development and dissemination of
technologies that will solve the problem
you need a set of policies most
importantly you need a price on carbon
if there is a price on carbon
companies will have the incentive to
invest in R&D and develop low-carbon
solutions if you don't have such a price
then clearly the market is not going to
move towards a low-carbon future you can
certainly assist this through fiscal
measures could be incentives
disincentives regulation but ultimately
if we're looking for solutions then the
market has to be harnessed and the power
of the market has to provide some of
these solutions may I also say that
lifestyle changes are going to be
important now this is something which is
not a popular thing to voice and i
remember in bangkok when we released the
Working Group three report there was a
press conference at the end and I was
asked what kind of lifestyle changes
does the IPCC recommend so I had to
clarify that firstly the IPCC doesn't
recommend anything it only assesses
various options is for you to adopt what
you want but I said if you ask a
personal opinion I would submit that
people should eat less meat I said
you'll be healthier and so would the
planet but
but I might confess that didn't make me
very popular with my Latin American
colleagues however I'm only giving that
as an example there are other things
that we should really be doing governor
l told us about the importance of
ensuring that we have the minimal amount
of air conditioning that's essential for
human comfort comfort there are means by
which we can cut down on lighting there
are means by which we can cut down on
our transportation demand but in general
as she suggested if we can think of one
thing every day by which we reduce our
carbon footprint then there will be such
a collective and cumulative action and
such an outcome of all these efforts
that I think we would move in the right
direction now I've talked essentially at
the global level let me say something
finally on what I believe the developing
countries should do I come from a
developing country and I've been telling
everyone right from the top leadership
downwards that the developing countries
should not emulate what the developed
countries have done we certainly would
be repeating their mistakes if we were
to do the same thing and in recognition
of this fact and in order to practice
what one preaches I've personally
launched a program that I call lighting
a billion lives I find it a source of
anguish and deep disappointment that in
this day and age in the 21st century we
have 1.6 billion people who don't have
access to modern forms of energy or
electricity and 400 million of them live
in India now we can wait for coal-fired
power plants we can provide kerosene we
can provide all kinds of fuels for these
people to get lighting in their lives
firstly that's going to take a long time
secondly I am not too sure those are
sustainable and environmentally clean
solutions so in my Institute we have
developed a solar Lantern and a solar
flashlight
and each of these can be provided to the
poorest of people I want to mention just
one example in villages in sunderbans
which is the Delta region of the river
Ganges the Ganga river you got a number
of islands which have no electricity
what we've done is we have trained a
woman in each village with a solar panel
on her roof she charges about 50
lanterns during the day and rents them
out in the evening to all the people in
the village the result is she's got a
job she's earning an income everyone has
a durable and sustainable form of
lighting and those who had cottage
enterprise in their homes are now
working longer hours because of the
light and children can read and study so
I think we need to think out of the box
and this can be done collaboratively
this can be done in partnership between
developed and developing countries
because after all we all live on one
planet and we have to face the challenge
together thank you very much
thank you so much dr. Pachauri for those
informative and inspiring remarks and
now it is an honor and a very special
pleasure for me to introduce Governor
Arnold Schwarzenegger I'm a native
Californian long ago I was lured here by
the irresistible attractions of this
place and have never gone home but I've
long had a special pride in seeing
California play a leadership role among
the states in protecting the environment
it's a long tradition and that pride has
been reinforced and strengthened by
Governor Schwarzenegger Zac shins to
confront and contain global warming his
administration pressed the Environmental
Protection Agency either take action to
address greenhouse gas emissions or to
get out of the way and let the state of
California do it
my home state was one of the 12 that
forced the issue of whether the epa has
the authority to regulate greenhouse
gases and they won at the united states
supreme court california was the first
state to mandate an enforceable
economy-wide cap on greenhouse gas
emissions Governor Schwarzenegger has
committed California to cutting co2
emissions to 1990 levels by 2020 a
twenty-five percent reduction in
California is aiming for an eighty
percent reduction by 2050 Governor
Schwarzenegger is a thoughtful and
committed champion of the environment he
speaks directly and eloquently about
leaving the world better than our
generation found it he understands
intuitively that green technologies will
create jobs and strengthen our economy
and that markets for carbon trading can
succeed and that the economy of the
state of California like the rest of the
country is robust enough to absorb the
cost of a carbon cap and trade system by
protecting the environment and exhorting
others to do the same Governor
Schwarzenegger continues in the
tradition of Theodore Roosevelt whom we
remember today his administration
exemplifies one of the strengths of the
American federal form of government when
it leaves States free to experiment and
to push the boundaries of public policy
as enthusiastic as I am about
experimentation and initiative that we
here seeing in California and in other
states there is one serious limitation
to state-level initiatives they don't
provide a uniform national approach that
would give certainty for consumers and
businesses nor would they ensure that
individual states are on a level playing
field in the carbon economy for that we
need indispensably national legislation
which I hope will be enacted soon Calif
California is demonstrating that we can
adopt measures to avert global warming
without excessive adverse economic
consequences in that sense Governor
Schwarzenegger is not merely leading
California but he is setting an example
for the nation and the world to follow
please join me in giving a warm welcome
to Governor Arnold Schwarzenegger
thank you very much president Levin for
the wonderful introduction and let me
just say right off the top and very
happy that I'm not the only one with an
accent speaking here today is great to
all have you dr. Pachauri thank you for
the wonderful speech it was really
extraordinary and I want to thank also
governor Jodi Rell for being here today
and all the other governors that came
and premiers it came down from Canada we
want to thank also Mary Nichols who is
the chair of the California yeah
resources port who is we does see that
they sitting in the front row thank you
very much you want to thank premier
sharae for being here from kupio cubic
and also we want to thank professor 10
st for being really responsible for
organizing this in for having me here
today and he has been a great adviser to
our administration for the last four
years we said we want to thank you for
all your great great burger king such a
great leader
and also want to thank one of our great
great advisors environmental advisors
Terry tamminen for being here today I
don't know where theory is but oh yeah
he's right here Terry get up it's really
great to be here the baby doll of you
and the be at Yale earlier I don't know
if you know but the president Levin and
Ivy create a little bit of action we
went over to the gym and we worked out
already I have no idea that he was that
buff to be honest with you he bench
press the sophomore which was really
extraordinary but anyway it is great to
be heated and I know that this is an
environmental conference an
environmental conference to mark Teddy
Roosevelt's 1908 yield governor's
conference and it is extraordinary event
here to celebrate this but even though
it's an environmental conference I would
like to start talking about bodybuilding
I see how everyone is waking up now I
like that now the reason is because the
there's something in common that the
image that bodybuilding had and the
image that environmentalists have in the
old days when I came over here 40 years
ago the America people worked up with
weights but they were embarrassed to
admit it to talk about bodybuilding
saying that their body below the work
that bid weights because they were
embarrassed about it especially big
stars in Hollywood like Kirk Douglas and
clean Eastwood Charles Bronson and those
guys they would not want to be
associated with the dungeons where those
weird guys that's fanatics trained so
they always when they were asked how did
he get this body they would say both we
were born like this but then slowly the
image changed because a book pumping
iron came out and then the movie pumping
iron came out as a matter of fact we
have to direct the sitting right here
where they were director George partly
is sitting right here
give him a big hand and they'd explained
the sport a little bit and all of a
sudden t1 order covers of magazines and
in newspapers and on television and I
started promoting the sport all over the
United States and all over the world and
the sport became want more popular and
eventually the perception of
bodybuilding began to change and the day
their gymnasiums everywhere and
everywhere you can go to ala gymnasium
anywhere and normal people will be
talking about the apps and the delts and
surat us and the six-pack and all of
those kind of things it's quite normal
so the sport has arrived now like
bodybuilders environmentalists we
thought also to be kind of weird
fanatics you know the kind of serious
tree huggers and weeping willows glossy
environmentalists were no fun that they
were like prohibitionists at the
fraternity party and stuff like that and
for two for too long environmental
movement was powered by guilt now you
know the kind of guilt that i'm talking
about smokestacks belching pollution to
power our hot tubs and large screen TVs
or in my case flying around with the
private plane or driving my big Hummers
now it's too bad that it can't live if
you all can live simple lives like
Buddhist monks and straw mats but you
know something it's not going to happen
let's face it people are not going to
give up their energy burning plasma TVs
maybe if the TV or the computer or the
cell phone or the appliance would have a
little smoke stack on it that shows you
that how much energy you use or how much
greenhouse gas emissions there are maybe
you would make the people feel a little
bit more guilty but I doubt it ladies
and gentlemen I don't think that any
movement has ever made it and has ever
made much progress based on guilt guilt
is passive it is inhibiting its
defensive and approach to simply doesn't
work successful movements are built on
passion they're built on confidence
they're built on Teddy Roosevelt's bully
pulpit they're built on critical mass
and off the
they're built in an element of alarm
that galvanizes action I believe the
environmental movement is switching over
from being powered by guilt to being
powered by something much more positive
something much more dynamic I mean much
more capable of bringing about
revolutionary change its image is also
changing from one of hand-wringing and
whining do that is more hip an image of
it is cutting-edge forceful and
self-confident and even sexy and the big
boost is coming after of course after
the election no matter whether it's
McCain or Obama or Clinton but it is
something we're going to talk about a
little bit later in California we of
course doing everything that we can to
change the balance of power on the
environment first let me start with
government policy now of course the big
thing is we don't wait for Washington
because as I've always said Washington
is asleep at the wheel
now I don't want to go into all the
details of all the laws that we have
passed and all the regulations and all
of the things that we have done but we
are I want to mention some of the things
because we are very proud of what we
have accomplished some effect when we
started and they said that he can't
protect the environment and economy at
the same time people said it was
impossible but then when I came into
office we started getting the work and
we started building the hydrogen highway
and we set aside 25 million acres of
pristine land with the Sierra Nevada
Conservancy then we put in place the
ocean action plan that led the nation in
cleaning and preserving our coastline we
also began our green building initiative
to make our government buildings more
energy-efficient but twenty-five percent
by the Year 2015 then we did something
very important which is we passed a
million solar roof initiative in order
to harness the renewable energy of the
Sun and then there were two things that
we have done to Los that we've passed
they got world recognition and that is
to pass the law of the cut greenhouse
gas emissions by twenty-five percent for
the year 2020 which is holding back the
greenhouse gas emissions to the 1990
level and in an additional eighty
percent by the year 2050 and then the
following year we thank
and then the following year we had to be
passed and we ordered a cut in a carbon
content of transportation fuels the
low-carbon fuel standards now like I
said this gave his world attention but
do I believe that those standards that
California sets were solve global
warming no not at all we would be a
doing is basically applying leverage so
that at some point the whole
environmental thing tilts and shifts
legacy saw go up and eventually it tilts
down the other way California is as you
know the seventh largest economy in the
world and it is a big state it's a
powerful state what we do does have
consequences they even though when you
look at the globe California is a little
spot on the globe but when it comes to
our power of influence it is an
equivalent of a whole continent never in
California passed its global warming act
Mary mind give me what told me alone
there was no one out there doing the
same thing because as I said Washington
didn't lead but we started forming
partnerships partnerships with western
states with north eastern states in the
Canadian provinces and the European
nations as America with all European
nations and then 600 American cities
have signed on to be part of the kyoto
treaty so America has to lead and we are
doing so even without Washington now
thank you
the things were going really well and
there's great progress being made but
not everything goes smoothly the are
stumbling blocks along the way like for
instance a year or so ago there was a
billboard in Michigan that accused me of
costing the car industry 85 billion
dollars because of our new emission
standards the billboard said arnold's to
Michigan dropped dead but that's not
what i'm saying what i'm saying is
arnold to michigan get off your butt
that's what I'm saying
as a matter of fact California may be
doing more to save the US auto industry
than anyone else because we are pushing
them to change so that if they want to
sell their cars in the Golden State they
should change the technology but
government by itself cannot get us where
we need to go I'm a big believer in
American technology and I think that
technology is what eventually will save
Detroit and will save the environment
but we have seen over and over people
talking about how bad the big jets are
obeyed the picasa but that's not the
action is what the size of something is
the action is in technology a perfect
example is for instance we in California
have a car company called Tesla Motors
where the tesla roadster is one hundred
percent electric this car goes from zero
to 60 in four seconds and it drives 140
miles an hour as a matter of fact
President 11 you need to have one of
those cars and tell you because the
girls will go crazy man this you in this
car I know you will be excited that that
anyway the tesla roadster goes 250 miles
on a charge and then it don't only take
three and a half hours to charge it up
now of course there's a downside because
the first version of the car will cost a
hundred thousand dollars but the second
one will come down to eighty thousand
dollars and the third version will be
fifty thousand dollars so economics tell
see where this is heading it's just like
me two cell phones twenty years ago
about her cell phone which was kind of a
radiophone and because sixteen hundred
dollars then eventually went down two
thousand dollars to 500 and the last
phone i bought for my daughter was only
ninety dollars so that they sell phones
at everywhere because of the costs
coming down the same thing will happen
with environmental technologies but
government as i said cannot do it all
but government can give a push by
setting the standards so California is
giving the nation and the world a push
and this is my un secretary-general ban
ki-moon came to me llego and asked me to
do a keynote speech at the United
Nations in order to talk there about
what California is doing and to give the
rest of the world a push because they're
190 some countries sitting there and we
try to inspire them to go in the same
direction as California's now of course
beyond government policy a second factor
is economic California is a lead the
leading edge of what i call the
environmental economy which is green
clean technology right now in
california's university labs corporate
research parks even in strip mall
offices something very exciting is
happening the nation's brightest
scientists and the smartest venture
capitalists of racing racing to fight
blue technologies for alternative energy
now this is a race that is literally
fueled by billions and billions of
dollars and when it comes to developing
green tech in California everyone is
drinking red bull I can tell you that
even the most optimistic forecasters say
that we only have 40 or 50 years of oil
left as a matter of fact be the first
that we see in India that India has and
the China has I think those years even
less so there's a huge pressure
besides global warming to push in the
direction of finding new sources of
energy so capitalism long the alleged
enemy of the environment is the day
giving new life to the environmental
movement in fact the environmental cause
would be unwinnable without capitalism
and the technology it will provide some
havoc the head of PG and E California's
largest utility says that the energy
industries and a brink of a revolution
General Electric based right here in
Connecticut sword its plastic business
because it's all more potential for
growth and profit in environmental goods
in services so you can see the shift is
happening and the shift is not only
happening here in America we seed all
over the world I saw the other day that
a leading German consulting firm
predicted that by the end of the next
decade more people will be employed in
Germany's in Germany's green clean
technology industry than in the auto
industry so as you can see is it's not a
fairy tale we have had the Industrial
Revolution the technological revolution
the global revolution and next is the
environmental revolution and I see
now I see some people looking at me
funny and saying what happened to the
sexual revolution well we're going to
talk about that the next time I come
here promise you so anyway the third
thing that I want to mention is the
attitude of the public the politicians
and also the special interests the
geopolitics of global climate change has
been deadlocked we all know that the US
says that China and India should be
covered by carbon limits and China and
India is saying that we should go first
because we were the biggest polluters in
the world but i think that the deadlock
is about to be broken President McCain
President Obama President Clinton I
think we'll all shift this country into
a much higher gear when it comes to
climate change as a matter of fact I'm
very happy to say that all three
candidates will be great for the
environment so things will immediately
pick up pick up speed after the
inauguration day I know that for sure
but let me tell you something that will
surprise you I don't know if many of you
know but I'm sure you do know that cable
TV show called Mythbusters you know that
show but is too funny weird guys go
around and trying to see various if
various different myth actually true
like dropping from 100 feet in the water
does it have the same impact as dropping
from 100 feet on the concrete or cement
or if you drop a penny from the Empire
State Building and it hits then below is
someone on ahead does that penny really
goes through someone's skull that's the
kind of crazy things that they try to
prove and I love their dummy that
they're using I mean he's really getting
beaten up he should actually go into
politics that's what I suggest well I
got a myth for those guys to investigate
because we hear all the time that
businesses and Republicans are the
obstacle to progress and renewable
energy and and greenhouse gases while
the environmental activists and
Democrats are absolutely perfect and
create no obstacle at all well I say
this is a myth first major companies
like DuPont and GE and walmart and B
p are convinced of the need for change
in mainstream republicans are finally
coming around to they realize the green
clean technology creates jobs extra
revenues and stimulate the economy but
the important point i want to make is
that environmental activists and
democrats many times are just as much an
obstacle in moving forward rhetorically
of course they love to talk about
renewable energy and geothermal and went
and soul and all those kind of things
but many times we have seen they're
trying to slow down the approval process
it's kind of a schizophrenic behavior
they say that we want to renewable
energy but we don't want you to put it
anywhere and you may not only to use it
one energy expert the other day said
that the California Mojave Desert which
is a bath space with thousands of square
miles is one of the best spots on planet
Earth for solar power plants Pacific Gas
and Electric once they put three huge
solar plants right there and the whole
world the Germans the French the
Canadians the Japanese they all want to
come out to California and put the solar
power plants in the Mojave Desert and in
other places the only thing is is that
the problem is that getting that new
energy to the power grid because of
environmental hurdles san diego gas and
electric wants to develop solar
geothermal fields in imperial valley and
build 150 miles of transition
transmission lines to go and take this
power right into san diego but it faces
opposition even though it would replace
an old carbon-based power plant so the
point i'm making is it's not just
businesses that have slowed things down
it's not just the public instead of slow
things down so the Democrats and those
environmental activists something to
slow things down and even my own agency
that I supposed to be the head off and
the boss off I found out is slowing
things down now this gets very
complicated I tell you for example our
Department of fishing game is slowing
approval of a solar facility in
victorville
it's because of an endangered squirrel
an endangered squirrel which has never
been seen on that land where they're
supposed to build the solar plants but
if such a squirrel were around this is
the kind of area that it would like they
say now the department wants the power
company to buy three acres of land to
protect this little creatures for every
acre of solar land that is being used so
that the squirrel could be safe if it
exists so a squirrel they may not exist
is holding up environmental progress on
the large and more pressing fight
against global warming what the half
years is a case of environmental
regulations holding up environmental
progress I don't know whether this is
ironical absurd but I mean if we cannot
put solar power plants in the Mojave
Desert I don't know where the hell we
can put it I tell you honestly this is
ladies and gentlemen this
ladies and gentlemen this is the real
world we have to make some trade-offs I
think both environmental activists and
their opponents cannot let perfect
become the enemy of possible because the
fact of the matter is nothing is perfect
solar still needs transmission lines
battery electric electric cars still
need chemicals in the batteries and
electricity to recharge them hydrogen
cars still need a fuel currently made
largely from natural gas nuclear power
which is very clean but still has waste
it must be stored somewhere biofuels
from corn based ethanol and palm oil
lead it still needs to be controlled so
we don't have to forest station all over
the world so it's my one of my
environmental friends and advisors said
that there is no silver bullets only
silver buckshot we need to find creative
ways to overcome those obstacles there's
no two ways about at night a business no
environmentalists no Republicans or
Democrats can be set in their ways I
suggested them relax exhale just exhale
and relax and let's things move forward
and what is so great about this
conference for instance yes there's a
lot of young people and I always found
that young people are more open to new
ways of thinking so I urge you to
continue to be open-minded on our
environment do not dismiss do not do not
accept an idea because it has a
Republican label or a democratic labour
a conservative flavor or a liberal label
think for yourself this is especially
true an environment so I have great
faith in your ability to find who
answers and define new approaches don't
accept what the old people say don't
accept but the old ways don't accept
your ways all the old politics of
Democrats and Republicans stir things up
be fresh and glue the way you look at
things I believe in what you can
now a lot of people are pessimistic
about the environmental problems and yes
there are a lot of obstacles but I am
optimistic I'm very optimistic earlier I
mentioned that one of the things that
proposed the propels a successful
movement is when it reaches critical
mass or ladies and gentlemen you can
feel the big things moving you can feel
the big things coming together you can
feel the momentum I say do not be
downhearted about the environment every
day I see what is happening in
California and I tell you my fellow
environmentalists things are about to
move our way thank you very much for
having me here and thank you for your
hospitality thank you